[Music]
can science actually provide absolute
answers and
um i suspect that the word absolute
there might be the the heart of this
question
um i don't know if any of you
immediately none of you seems to be
leaping at this point
i can certainly answer that because that
completely relates to what i was just
saying so let me just go into a little
bit more into what i mean by effective
an effective theory
is based on the idea that at any given
time
we've measured certain things in a
certain regime of parameters maybe a
certain distance regime a certain energy
regime or certain um
[Music]
whatever
size regime
um and we can make predictions we can
make successful predictions we can have
theories about that regime of parameters
now mind you that regime of parameters
becomes bigger and bigger as we expand
our measurements as we look at more
things but we have this very and and
those answers are correct up to
the accuracy with which we've measured
things
so it could be that either by measuring
things more accurately
or by moving to a different regime
we can find that our predictions were
not absolute as you put it they're not
precise but they were precise enough for
everything we had to do precise enough
to send a man to the moon but maybe
it could get more precise
and that would be irrelevant to anything
we see today which is why we're not and
we haven't measured that yet now
that
so i think it's very comforting and very
comfortable and helps get around a lot
of these silly debates to admit that
that's the way all knowledge works we
based it on what we've seen what we've
observed we put it together into
theories we can make predictions
uh science is unique in that we can
usually say the accuracy with which we
trust the predictions and then allow
things to evolve beyond that so
to say there's an absolute is
unnecessary in all of this we don't even
have to ask that question
all we have to do is ask the question is
it is it good enough for what we're
trying to do
in whatever we're trying to predict
whatever we're trying to build and
that's the sense in which science is
brilliantly successful and it's also
brilliantly successful in telling us
when we don't have absolute things i
mean what we're doing in particle
physics is we're looking for deviations
from this what we call the standard
model that's what tells us how to go
beyond it doesn't mean the standard
model is wrong it tells us that there
could be a richer structure that
underlies it and that's the way science
can evolve
can i just
can i just say here i think this term
absolute
is is again not being very helpful um
does
do do scientists come up sometimes with
true correct answers to certain
questions yes they do um what's supposed
to be absolute is
sometimes the evidence
that those answers are correct it leaves
them beyond any what we would call any
reasonable doubt
dna has a double helix structure that's
a really important discovery
if you're worried about covid
we know it's a virus right we got the
sequence very quickly those are not
those are really not
useful things that anyone can question
um
high-level theoretical physics is an
entirely different matter
you're not gonna ever be sure you have
that nailed down exactly right but we
sure do know a lot of stuff and we know
it beyond anything no but i'm saying let
me just to be clear even for something
like a virus yes it's a virus but maybe
it's a virus interacting with something
else so the virus is an approximation to
how we should be thinking about it of
course it's an extremely excellent
approximation just the way the standard
wall is an extremely excellent
approximation so you're right that when
we're really at the edge of knowledge of
course then these effective theories are
breaking down in ways that we can
manifest but there's a lot of stuff in
physics that's
on a solid ground is the kind of stuff
that you just mentioned and so i don't
mean to say that that doesn't exist i'm
just saying that if we do more
measurements maybe we i mean obviously
it acts like a virus there's no question
about it but there are other things that
we can learn about it that will enhance
our knowledge of what it is and how it's
interacting and how it takes it
interacts with its environment for
example
right
covid just is a virus i mean there are
lots of there are lots of issues that go
into how it affects the biological
mechanism and a lot of things can come
into that environmental factors but it
just is a virus and we know a lot about
its structure and so on i don't think
it's all that helpful to
spread a kind of general skepticism over
everything because then that will affect
people will say oh i can always question
anything
um at a certain point there are some
things that it's not really reasonable
to question and there are other things
that it is perfectly reasonable to
question and you have to look at each
individual case
that's why i think i i don't want a
bumper sticker
that says
science is x i mean then you even have
the question what counts as science we
don't think that astrology is science
we have good reasons not to think that
but you can't also just think that
science is some sticker you can stick on
things that suddenly makes it valid or
invalid or whatever
um
i think in this regard that uh you know
what scientists can do
is to
talk about where there is consensus you
know for example this cova thing is a
virus there's there's
no serious scientist questions that and
then the scientists can then say
so that's our common ground but here are
the here are the details where we might
just disagree where we might disagree on
the right interventions and and and and
so forth it requires a little bit more
attention from the public to to
understand these these nuances but if
science scientists could do this i think
it also could help with political
discourse to you know figure out where
do we agree
and then where where do we disagree and
and why what are the substantive issues
um
so scientists would would say there
no question about certain interventions
for the virus and certain things
there's no question about that
then the details about specific
details about masks and so forth how
effective those might be in different
circumstances there could be debate
among scientists on those on those
details and then then the public might
be
told look
we don't have the absolute answer here
but 90
of the scientists who've done this work
think such and such you know masks in
this situation but not in that
and 10 disagree so right now you know
the 10 percent might be right but right
now we have to go with the 90 percent um
and you know and two years from now we
might find something different so i just
i mean one thing that we do though often
is we um
we cite people we cite 90 of the people
but what would also be very useful is
that 90
of
the time
it was found that this works um rather
than make it a question of consensus or
people's opinion and and that is
actually sometimes a problem with the
way science is presented it's presented
as so and so says this and really it's
something based on something and often
when we talk to the public people are
afraid to say what the data is because
they won't necessarily understand it and
and this goes back to them talking about
providing evidence um there are there
are questions i mean really um and in
terms of interventions i don't think
there was a single intervention that
wasn't questioned in this country by
someone i mean so what we really need is
a better educational system
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you